baby backs a name so my powers become
yours I don't know your name for real
okay belly you ask me flight or
invisibility I thought that was stupid
but now I look like this I need your
help
oh oh oh thank god hey stop right there
how do I know you're not a supervillain
using telepathic abilities to make me
believe that you're Billy huh what's all
I got to do is press dial on this thing
no no I approve
look I lied okay I took your bullet Oh
stupid adult hands but you thought you
saw it right look Freddy I swear it's me
okay look I know we're not really close
friends or anything but you're the only
person that I know that knows anything
about this Cape Crusader stuff it's
Batman what forget it can I hate
that's crazy right
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing okay okay can you fly okay
let's do this how do we do this
just um just like Superman it I got
obviously you have to jump come on how
is it is obvious okay try to believe
that you can fly okay I read this deep
dive into peer-reviewed Studies own
superpowers and in six out of ten belief
is the key okay okay I believe I can fly
I believe that I believe I can fly did
you believe ya not find visibility how
do I do you forget it you know okay
alright okay okay oh my god it worked
where'd you go I'm right here you can't
see me we're over here [ __ ] I might
have been testing invisibility and super
intelligence at the same time Freeman
I'm gonna come over there and beat you
oh my god the lightning and blue staring
us right in the face the whole time
literally hey everybody it's Charlie so
they released an extended preview for
the Shazam movie with a whole bunch of
new footage that will breakdown and
early reviews are also out there
starting to screen the movie so we'll do
a breakdown of that and we have new
details on the Black Adam movie so
there's a whole bunch of shows and
related stuff going on it's all good
you'll be pleased to know we'll do a new
round of the IMAX ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this the reason why we have the new
Shazam footage is because they just
released
Aquaman on digital I think it's hitting
blu-ray sometime soon - but this was on
that release so it's just him getting
his powers in the immediate scene after
that where he goes straight to Freddy
Freeman for help do you have to help me
and Freddy just totally freaking out
because this is obviously real the
Justice League exists in this world so
superheroes superpowers are real that's
why freddy freeman drops the reference
about telepathy how do i know that
you're not a supervillain using
telepathic abilities on me making me
believe that you're Billy that's
actually a doctor light reference even
though Gorilla Grodd is a telepath
usually he uses his abilities to make
people do things not to fool people into
believing that he's a superhero or
someone else he loses Freddy Freeman's
Batman bullet from Batman V Superman
down the drain stupid adult hands that's
actually a bullet that Batman fired at
Superman during this scene here because
superheroes are so common and people
have gotten so used to the idea it's
turned into a cottage industry so like
you have scavengers that will go find
stuff that the Justice League leaves
behind after their big saves and try to
sell it on eBay which actually does
sound like something that people would
do in real life
if these superheroes were real just
literally sell anything that you could
slap their name on or anything that they
brushed past during a safe this is
something that Superman touched while he
was saving someone thousand dollars on
eBay for the most part Freddy Freeman is
the superhero expert just because he's
such a fanboy early in the movie Billy
doesn't really start out in the movie
believing in superheroes power now he
knows that they're real but he doesn't
worship them like a lot of other
kids would like everyone would look up
to Superman Batman Wonder Woman these
characters but Billy's life has been so
crap up to this point he's about 14
years old he's a freshman in high school
so he's getting ready to turn 15 that's
why in the other trailers you hear
talking to dr. sivana I'm basically 15
his whole arc in the movie is just
embracing that idea so the Shazam family
is a big part of that I'll talk about in
a second especially when I start talking
about the early reviews in the music cue
that you hear when he touches his
lightning emblem sounds a lot like John
Williams Superman theme that's
definitely on purpose because a lot of
this movie is meant to be classic
Superman mixed with Tom Hanks big all
the jokes about Freddie punking him just
telling him he needs to believe that he
has superpowers six out of ten times
having superpowers is just about
believing that you have superpowers and
then telling him he's totally invisible
he was a pretty good idea of their scene
chemistry together
I feel like Dylan grazier that's who
this Freddie Freeman actor is has great
scene partner chemistry with Zachary
Levi so they work really well together
in scenes but within the context of the
Shazam character one of the really cool
things that he can do is cast regular
magical spells just like any other
magical character in the DC Universe
like Zatanna he's very very powerful so
his abilities go beyond just the visual
powers that you've seen in all the
trailers is just that Billy Batson has
no idea how to cast spells yet so
there's so many things that he'll
discover he can do through the course of
the film it's just a really obvious ones
that they start out with like magical
lightning oh was staring us in the face
the whole time or him trying to learn
how to fly or just learning that he has
quote-unquote bullet immunity during the
convenience-store save there's the way
more complex abilities like the wisdom
of Solomon things like that that'll come
out a little bit later in the film
albeit in the same funny way that they
discovered these powers like oh my gosh
I didn't realize that I had SuperSpeed
so the really cool thing that the studio
just did Warner Brothers is that they
screen the movie or started screening
the movie for critics and it is way
earlier than they usually screen movies
for people which gives you a pretty good
idea for how the studio feels people are
gonna react to the movie because
typically you hear about embargoes being
like right before movies come out when
studios aren't sure if a movie is gonna
do well like suni would not let critics
release their venom reviews - like the
day or two before venom came out in
theaters because they were so worried
about what critics were gonna say about
that movie they were quite
so hard with critics on Aquaman but they
still made people wait till like the
last possible minute before they
released it reviews for that but as
you've probably seen the last couple of
days they've let critics start talking
about Shazam a month before the movie
comes out which means that they are
really really confident that people will
like the movie so if you're really
hoping for a solid DC movie that's
really enjoyable then you will probably
enjoy shows AM it's a little bit like
Christopher Reeves original Superman
movie Tom Hanks big a little bit Goonies
in there Zachary Levi said that they
wanted it to feel like a classic Steven
Spielberg Amblin film that's where you
get a lot of The Goonies of it all and
that has two lot to do with the Shazam
family the kids a group of kids like you
have the it movie which is a group of
kids you have stranger things group of
kids which are all things that are
riffing on classic Steven Spielberg
films like et just kids riding their
bikes around having adventures together
so there's a lot of that in the Shazam
movie as you've seen in all the trailers
it wears its heart on its sleeve nails a
lot of the character relationships
especially the Shazam family in Billy
Batson's relationship with his own
powers it is a little bit over the top
on purpose in a very self-aware way the
same way that some of the humor in
Aquaman was way over the top on purpose
Shazam sells it just as well as Jason
Momoa
sold it during Aquaman so if you enjoyed
Aquaman you thought that was a fun movie
then you probably won't have any
problems with the jokes or the style of
humor that Shazam goes with as you've
seen in a lot of the trailers half of
the fun of the movie is just how hard
they leaned on other DC movie references
and not just DC EU movie references like
Justice League and Batman V Superman
that's a lot of it but there's a lot of
wider DC movie and TV shows baked into
the movie like this funny scene from the
last trailer with him throwing the
Batman toy at dr. sivana where it says
I'm Batman
that's actually Kevin Conroy voice doing
his version of Batman from Batman the
Animated Series so much of that stuff is
baked into the movie some of it is more
subtle than other references and while
they do make fun of a lot of the other
bigger DC movies they never demonized
them or make fun of them in a really
hateful way they do a really good job of
balancing the broader comedy like I said
there are a lot of really big jokes that
they lean on during the film but they
balanced that really well with the
darker villain tone which will he'll
give you an idea for what future sequels
will
feel like when they try to cross the
characters over with Black Adam because
his tone is way darker than any of this
stuff so they do have moments like that
during the film to get a little bit
darker the director David Sandberg is
mostly known for doing indie horror
films just like James Wan before he did
Aquaman so when they do eventually get
to Black Adam it'll be a little more
believable that you can have someone as
crazy as that working with someone as
light and broad as the Shazam character
and just in general it feels like a
really solid hit for them but I will
have to see the movie a couple more
times before I do a real review moving
into Black Adam movie territory they're
supposed to start shooting Black Adam
March 2020 so about a year from right
now as I'm posting this video which
means that the movie would come out
during 2021 at some point websites have
started reporting that the script
supposedly features Hawkman in a few
Justice Society characters including
atom smasher in star girl which if that
sounds confusing I think implies that it
takes place in present day because of
the star curve at all Hawkman can exist
across eons because of his reincarnation
so he could be a character that has
history with Black Adam
but since Hawkman is such a hardcore
character I think that just lets you
know that the tone of Black Adam will be
way darker in more hardcore than the
Shazam movie but I have a zero opinion
on atom smasher the only live-action
version of that character we've seen so
far is on the flash season 2 and he was
played by edge from WWE if you are a big
fan of Jeff Jones Justice Society run
from the early 2000s it seems like they
might borrow a little bit from that for
the Black Adam movie but that's just an
early report so as we get more
information about that I'll post more
videos but I'm expecting by Comic Con
later this year we'll get some solid
info on what's going on with it there'll
be some new Marvel and Game of Thrones
stuff posting soon leave all your DC
video requests in the comments below
congratulations John P you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for my Captain Marvel
post-credit scene video and click here
to learn why they're ending the arrow TV
show on DC TV thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight